한 나라의 미래를 볼 때 보통 어떤 걸 봐야 한다고 생각하시나요?
보통은 반도체 투자액을 봅니다.
AI 논문이 얼마나 나오는지도 보고
정부가 어느 산업의 예산을 쓰는지도 봅니다.
대기업들이 어디에 투자하겠다고 발표하는지도 중요한 지표로 보죠.
그런데 저는 오늘 조금 다른 지표를 보려고 합니다.
바로 그 나라에서 가장 공부를 잘하는 학생들이 어디로 가는가
그리고 그 사회가 어떤 직업에 가장 큰 보상을 주는가입니다.
왜냐하면 인재들은 말로 움직이지 않기 때문입니다.
정부가 아무리 AI가 중요하다, 반도체가 중요하다, 바이오가 중요하다고 말해도
실제로 돈을 많이 벌고 안정적이고 사회적으로 인정받는 직업이 따로 있다면
학생들은 그쪽으로 갑니다.
결국 인재는 구호가 아니라 보상체계를 보고 움직입니다.
이번 이야기의 핵심도 여기에 있습니다.
중국은 지금 의사와 금융권의 매력을 낮추고 있습니다.
그리고 AI, 반도체, 에너지,
로봇같은 전략기술 분야의 보상을 키우고 있습니다.
반대로 한국은 말로는 AI와 반도체, 바이오를 말하고 있지만
최상위권 학생들에게 가장 강력한 선택지는 여전히 의대입니다.
그래서 우리가 던져야 할 질문은
한국은 지금 미래산업을 키우고 있는 걸까요?
아니면 미래산업에 가야할 인재를 잃고 있는 걸까요?
오늘은 중국이야기로 시작해보겠습니다.
중국의 방식이 옳다는 이야기가 아닙니다.
오히려 중국식 통제는 여러 부작용을 만들 수 있습니다.
다만 우리가 봐야할 것은 중국이 어떤 방식으로 인재의 흐름을 바꾸고 있는가 입니다.
먼저 의료분야부터 보겠습니다.
중국의 의료문제를 볼 때
단순히 의사가 부패했다,
병원이 돈만 밝힌다는 식으로만 보면
전체의 흐름을 놓치기 쉽습니다.
이 문제의 출발점은
1980년대 의료기업까지 거슬러 올라갑니다.
당시 중국은 병원 건물이나 기본 인프라는 국가가 지원하되
실제 운영비는 병원이 스스로 벌도록 하는 방향으로
의료체계를 바꿨습니다.
문제는 병원에는 알아서 돈을 벌려고 하면서도
정작 진료비와 수술비는 낮게 묶어뒀다는 점입니다.
병원 입장에서 보면 환자를 진료하고 수술하는 본업만으로는
충분한 운영비를 마련하기 어려웠습니다.
정부 지원 비중은 줄어들었고 병원은 계속 운영되어야 했습니다.
그러다 보니까 병원은 자연스럽게 약품 판매, 정밀검사, 상의병실,
고가 의료 소모품 같은 곳에서 수익을 찾게 됩니다.
이러한 흐름은 2009년 2차 의료기업 때 한 번 더 바뀝니다.
당시 후진타오 정부는 공립병원은 공익으로 돌아가야 한다는 명분을 내세웠습니다.
방향 자체는 타당했습니다.
병원이 약을 많이 팔아 수익을 내는 구조를 줄이겠다는 취지였기 때문입니다.
그래서 병원이 약값에 붙이던 마진을 없애는
이른바 약값 마진 0% 정책이 확대됩니다.
하지만 문제는 그 다음이었습니다.
약값 마진을 없애면 병원 수입이 줄어들 수밖에 없습니다.
그렇다면 줄어든 수입을 진료비 현실화나 정부 보조금으로 충분히 매워줘야 했습니다.
그런데 현실에서는 이 보완이 충분하지 않았습니다.
결국 병원과 의사들은 다시 다른 수익 통로를 찾게 됩니다.
제약회사 리베이트, 수술 전 의사에게 전달되는 빨간 봉투,
고가 의료 소모품 사용, 불필요한 CT나 MRI 처방 같은 방식이 커진 배경도 여기에 있는 겁니다.
여기서 중요한 교훈이 하나 나옵니다.
이렇게 공식 보상을 낮게 묶어두면
비공식 보상이 커질 가능성이 높아진다는 겁니다.
제도 안에서 정상적으로 보상받기 어렵다면
제도 밖의 수익 통로가 생기기 쉬운 구조가 만들어집니다.
그런데 2023년에 시진핑 정부가 의료계의 대대적인 반부패 캠페인을 시작합니다.
이번에는 병원과 의사들이 그동안 의존해온 비공식 수입 통로를 직접적으로 건드렸습니다.
리베이트, 강연료, 학회비, 의료기기 업체와의 부적절한 거래, 수술 전후, 촌지 등이 조사 대상이 됐습니다.
이 조치의 의미는 분명합니다.
중국 정부가 의료계에 사실상 이렇게 말한 겁니다.
이제 비공식 수입으로 버티지 말고 공식 월급으로 살아라.
그런데 여기서 문제가 생깁니다.
중국 의사들의 공식 소득이 그렇게 높지 않다는 점입니다.
중국 의사는 오래 공부하고 임상 훈련도 거쳐야 하며 병원에 들어가면 많은 환자를 봐야 합니다.
그런데 공식 보상은 기대보다 낮고 비공식 수입도 단속으로 줄어들고 있습니다.
그러면 학생 입장에서는 의사가 되는 길에 매력이 떨어질 수밖에 없습니다.
의학을 공부했다고 해서 반드시 병원 의사가 되는 것이 아니라
제약회사나 의료기기 회사로 가거나 헬스케어 스타트업, 공무원, 연구직으로 이동하는 선택지가 더 현실적으로 보일 수 있습니다.
결과적으로 중국은 의사라는 직업의 기대 수익을 낮춘 셈입니다.
이것이 처음부터 의도된 결과인지 아니면 정책이 누적되면서 생긴 부작용인지는 따져볼 필요가 있습니다.
중국에서 의사는 한국처럼 최상위권 학생들이 무조건 몰리는 직업은 아니라는 점입니다.
의료 다음으로 중국이 손댄 곳은 금융업입니다.
중국 정부는 금융권의 높은 임금과 성과급 구조도 조정하기 시작했습니다.
국유 금융기업에는 임금 격차를 줄이고 성과급을 바로 지급하지 않고 일정 기간 뒤로 미루며
문제가 생기면 이미 지급한 보수도 환수할 수 있도록 하는 관리 방식이 요구됐습니다.
이외에는 금융감독 기관 직원들은
급여까지 낮추는 조치가 추진됐습니다.
이것은 단순한 예산 절감으로만 보기 어렵습니다.
금융권은 중국에서도 소득이 높고 안정적인 좋은 직장이었습니다.
그런데 중국 정부는 그 직업의 매력을 낮추고 있습니다.
왜 그럴까요?
중국 입장에서는 우수한 인재가 금융으로 과도하게 몰리는 것이 부담일 수 있습니다.
특히 미국과 기술 경쟁을 벌이는 상황에서 중국이 지금 필요로 하는 인재는 단순히 돈을 굴리는 사람이 아닙니다.
반도체를 설계하고
AI 모델을 개발하고
로봇을 만들고
에너지 기술을 확보하는 사람이 필요합니다.
그래서 중국은 금융권의 초과보상을 낮추고
대신 전략기술 분야의 보상을 높이는 방향으로 움직이고 있습니다.
여기서 중국의 의도가 보입니다.
의료에서는 의사의 비공식 수입 통로를 막고
금융에서는 고인군과 성과급 구조를 낮추고 있습니다.
반대로 AI, 반도체, 로봇, 에너지 같은 분야에서는
높은 보상이 빠르게 늘고 있습니다.
이건 단순히 의료 부패를 잡는다거나
금융권 임금을 깎는다는 이야기로만 볼 문제가 아닙니다.
더 크게 보면 중국은 지금 직업별 보상 체계를 다시 조정하고 있습니다.
어떤 직업이 더 많은 돈을 벌어야 하는지
어떤 산업에 우수한 인재가 몰려야 하는지를
국가 전략과 연결시키고 있는 겁니다.
물론 이 방식은 위험합니다.
의료와 금융을 강제로 누르면 시장 기능이 왜곡될 수 있고
전문직의 동기가 떨어질 수도 있습니다.
우수한 인재가 해외로 빠져나갈 가능성도 있습니다.
하지만 한 가지는 분명합니다.
중국은 AI, 반도체, 에너지, 로봇 같은 전략 기술 분야의
인재를 집중시키려고 하고 있습니다.
중국의 고임금 집권을 보면 이 방향은 더 선명해집니다.
최근 중국에서는 AI 연구 개발, 대형 모델 알고리즘,
반도체 설계, IC 검증, 로봇 분야의 인재의 몸값들이
빠르게 올라가고 있습니다.
이것은 단순한 연봉 뉴스가 아닙니다.
중국 사회가 앞으로 어떤 인재에게 가장 높은 가격을
매기고 있는지를 보여주는 신호입니다.
기술 격차는 하루아침에 좁혀지지 않습니다.
처음에는 학생들의 전공 선택이 바뀝니다.
그 다음에는 대학원과 연구실의 방향이 바뀌고
이후에는 기업의 채용과 투자가 바뀝니다.
그리고 시간이 지나면 그 결과가 산업 경쟁력으로 나타납니다.
중국은 지금 바로 이 앞단에서 변화를 만들고 있습니다.
이제 한국도 한번 볼까요?
한국도 반도체를 말하고 AI를 말하고
바이오와 로봇을 말합니다.
정부도 첨단 산업을 키우겠다고 하고
기업도 대규모 투자를 발표합니다.
그런데 여기서 더 중요한 질문이 하나 남습니다.
한국의 가장 뛰어난 학생들은 실제로 어디로 가고 있습니까?
한국에서 의대는 여전히 최상위권 학생들에게
가장 강력한 선택지입니다.
이건 학생들을 비난할 문제가 아닙니다.
의대는 소득이 높고 안정적이며 사회적 인정도 큽니다.
개인 입장에서는 매우 합리적인 선택입니다.
반대로 AI 연구자, 반도체 설계자,
바이오 연구자, 로봇 엔지니어는
국가적으로는 중요하지만 개인에게는 불확실성이 큽니다.
연구 기간은 길고 성과는 예측하기 어렵고
보상과 안정성도 의사보다 약하다고 느끼기 쉽습니다.
문제는 개인에게 합리적인 선택이
국가 전체에는 위험한 결과로 이어질 수 있다는 점입니다.
한국이 계속 첨단 산업을 말하면서도
최상위 인재가 의대로만 향한다면
반도체 공장은 있어도
다음 세대 반도체를 설계할 인재가 부족해질 수 있습니다.
AI 서비스를 쓰는 기업은 많아도
세계적인 AI 모델을 만드는 인재는 부족할 수 있고
바이오 산업을 키운다고 해도
장기 연구를 버틸 연구자가 줄어들 수 있습니다.
한국은 제조업 강국입니다.
하지만 앞으로의 경쟁은
공장을 많이 짓는 것만으로는 이길 수 없습니다.
AI 모델을 누가 설계하는지,
시스템 반도체 구조를 누가 만드는지,
제조 공장을 누가 자동화하는지,
로봇과 AI를 산업 현장에
누가 더 빨리 적용하는지가 중요해집니다.
여기에는 최상위 엔지니어와 과학자가 필요합니다.
장비와 투자도 중요하지만
결국 그것을 설계하고 개선할 사람이 부족해지면
경쟁력은 오래가기 어렵습니다.
한국이 지금의 인재 흐름을 바꾸지 못하면
중국과의 격차는 장비나 투자에서가 아니라
인재에서 먼저 좁혀질 수 있습니다.
그래서 한국이 배워야 할 것은
중국식 통제가 아닙니다.
의사보상을 억지로 낮추거나
금융권 임금을 강제로 깎자는 이야기가 아닙니다.
의료도 중요하고 금융도 중요합니다.
다만 한국이 반드시 봐야 할 것은 방향성입니다.
인재는 구호가 아니라
보상 체계를 따라 움직인다는 사실입니다.
AI와 반도체가 중요한지는 이미 모두가 알고 있습니다.
그런데 그 중요한 일을 하는 사람이
한국에서 충분히 보상받고 있습니까?
이 질문에 답하지 못하면
한국의 첨단 산업 전략은 계속 흔들릴 겁니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.